what is going on everybody and welcome
to another starcraft 2 ai video in the
last video we made this very very basic
kind of bare bones script all we're
doing is collecting resources with our
workers
and eventually the enemy comes and
destroys us that seems to be happening
within about a one to two thousand uh
steps so we probably want to learn how
to build up some base defenses to some
extent as well as just learning how to
like build buildings and what to build
and when and how to kind of navigate
around this like order of
operations that has to take place so at
least in this video what i'd like to
have us do is build some cannons at the
base
so in order to build those cannons
bringing over our kind of map of things
in order to build a photon cannon that's
what we want we need to first have a
forge and then again to have a forge we
need to have a nexus but we start with a
nexus so we should have one unless it's
been destroyed
so
uh closing this and then i'll just move
this out of the way
let's go ahead and begin our
logic so
um
so i'll continue just printing out the
iteration that's fine you can also print
out
various bits of information here
for debugging purposes if you want but
there are some things that are displayed
and you can kind of see them on the
screen anyways when you like build units
and build buildings you should be able
to see them
so anyway uh what we'll do is the first
thing that we're going to check is we're
going to check to see if
self.town halls
and essentially this is i think the
generic way of checking to see if a
nexus like thing exists so self.town
halls
is generic b
across the three races
so if there is a town hall that means we
have a nexus so we're going to say the
nexus equals self.town halls
and then we're going to grab a random
one
unless we've built more this will be our
only one anyways
but what if we don't have a town hall
right so what if we don't have that
nexus so if we don't actually have that
nexus what we're going to want to do is
build it so else
if self dot can underscore afford
and then we're going to do a unit type
id dot on an all caps nexus
so if we can afford a nexus we will
await a self.expand
underscore now
so um
we need to import the unit type id let
me see what that is too yeah so we'll go
up to the top here
and we will say from sc2.ids
ids
dot unit underscore type id we're going
to import
unit type
id
i'll put a link in the description as
well to
um
to async if you don't know much about
using async i'll have a link in the
description for kind of what to expect
with async
if you're curious to learn more but
essentially what this is going to do is
if we don't have a nexus our
top priority is to build a nexus
so um okay cool so if we do have a nexus
though what do we want to do so if we
have a nexus
one of the things that we can do is
build more of these little worker units
for the protoss class
uh and those are called probes
so one one thing we could say is if uh
nexa nexus dot is underscore idle and
self dot can underscore afford
the unit type id dot and all caps probe
so if we can afford a probe
we will do a nexus.train and we will do
unit type id dot and then all caps probe
so this will actually train our probe if
if we can
so if that's the case uh cool so we'll
make some probes now eventually you're
probably going to want to limit
uh the the actual probes
um
you're not gonna want like an infinite
number of probes uh but for now this
will be fine
so the next thing is pylons so for the
protoss class again all the classes are
a little different so but for the
protoss class in order to power your
buildings and to like warp in units
you use pylons and the pylons create
i forget the name of the matrix but it's
some sort of matrix
that so you kind of want all your pylons
close together and then in order to
build a building in some location you
have to have a pylon there to like power
it so we are going to need
some pylons so the next thing so first
of all we need probes how many probes we
need we'll identify that later but
you know in the order of importance we
need
our nexus
we need probes and then if we have
probes we want to use at least one of
those probes if we don't have any pylons
we want at least one pylon but probably
we'll want more over time but for sure
we want at least one pilot
so for example we could say l if
not self.structure
structures
and then again unit type
unit type id dot and all caps pylon
and then again and self dot already
pending
make sure it's not running over me cool
uh basically what we want to do is if if
that's not already pending so if
self.already pending unit type id dot
pylon
equals zero so if we don't have if we
can if we don't have any pylons and we
don't have any pylons that we're about
to build
then we're going to say if
can underscore
afford
so then the next question like basically
everything else if we can afford the
unit type id dot
pylon
if we can afford that then we will await
self dot build and then again unit type
id
uh pylon
and we're going to build that pylon
there's all these like little helper
things that you can do within this
package and we're going to say we want
to build it near
the nexus so again we've just defined
the nexus up here
now
for all of these things there are like
this is these are just nice nifty little
ways that we can like build things close
to other things but
this obviously you you this is
abstracting away exactly where you might
want to build that um that pylon so in
the future you might want to consider
possibly uh using even more advanced
logic besides just yeah build it
somewhere near this thing but this will
do for now
so
we the pylons along with providing
uh power to your buildings and the
ability to just build buildings and use
things and warp things in uh the other
thing that these pylons do is give you
like supply
and this supply you need supply for
buildings and units
so again one pylon probably is not going
to cut it for us so we're going to need
multiple pylons so again i'm just going
to now that we've had at least one pylon
so if you have no pylons you want to
build that first pylon near a nexus but
if you have at least one pylon then
basically from here on out you want to
build your subsequent pylons near other
pylons unless i guess maybe you're
starting a new location i don't know
i think they all need to be connected
though so what i'm going to say here is
elif self.structures
and then we're going to say unit type id
dot pylon
uh dot amount
amount
if the amount is less than five then
we're going to say if self dot can
afford uh and in fact i'm just going to
do this bloop and paste so if we can
afford one then what we want to do is
first we want to find the pylon that we
want to build it next to so
again i'm just
just take this with a grain of salt here
we're going to say that target pylon is
going to be equal to self.structures
self.structures
and then unit i almost need to like copy
and paste unit type id pylon
i've typed that out too many times
so we're going to say the pylon that is
dot closest underscore to
and then it'll be self dot enemy
underscore start locations and we'll say
zero so you could have multiple enemies
and in this case we just happen to have
one enemy um
and so we're just going to assume we
only have that one enemy and we're going
to continue expanding towards that enemy
this could be anything though it doesn't
have to be closest to that enemy it
could be closest to i don't know maybe
you'll identify what's the next like
cluster of resources that you want to
begin like mining
maybe you would want to expand that way
i'm just showing you the logic so so
this will be the logic that we're going
to use uh but there's probably way
better ideas here so
[Music]
do what you want with this uh so that's
the target pylon so this what we've done
so far is we've just said hey which
pylon do we want to like say this is the
pylon we want to build close to
that's the one so it's just the one that
is closest to the enemy's starting
location
so then what we're going to say is um
we have that pylon we're going to say
um
where do we want to essentially build
that pylon so we're going to say the
position that we want to build that
we're going to say is target underscore
pylon dot position dot towards
and then self dot enemy start locations
zero so we'll continue building it
towards that enemy start location and
then random.rand range
eight
to 15 and i that's i took that range
from i think one of the like starting
scripts um possibly i don't know anyways
it seems like that's like the range that
people are using for pylons like i said
it makes this little matrix and the
pylons like have to be in range of each
other in order to continue building out
that matrix so it just seems like that
is a good range to use so since we've um
called in random we haven't imported
that so we'll go ahead and import
random
so coming back down here
so that will be
the position that we want to build at
and then so finally we will
and in fact
we're going to do this we're going to
say await
and then rather than near nexus we're
going to say near
that
position i think that will suffice
okay
so
that will get us to build pylons and i
think what i'm going to do is uh i'd
like to run this real quick make sure
make sure we're not off to a terrible
start um
python3
sc2-2 dot pi
let us see what we've got up
okay so unit
um
se2
ids let's see if i've
typoed that um okay hold on
sc2
dot ids dot unit type id
import
what is the problem
i'm just going to copy and paste for my
notes and see
i don't know if i'm
unit
type id i honestly don't see it but
am i
what's the difference
no
oh
ah okay the capital it was the capital d
here
wow
rough that's a rough one um okay hashtag
programming i should have known that
like so many times it's that second
letter is not uh capitalized um
i i shouldn't have made that mistake but
oh well anyways uh okay try again
so all we're hoping for is we're still
gonna get crushed by the enemy ai
um but what i'm hoping to see is that
we
build more pylons towards the enemy up
and instead we we we do nothing unit oh
gosh we got to do we got to replace like
oh no it's just terrible
so we need to replace all the capital
ids with the undercase unit type id
right
well how many times okay so i guess it's
not case okay
um
all right
gosh
i'm just trying to test these pylons man
it's a lot of effort
okay
we are off uh i don't want to stream it
to my friends thank you
uh we can see actually supply has gone
up and indeed you know we've got a pylon
here this is a pylon this is a pylon
these are some pylons
these are more pylons so and you can see
this is the little matrix right so that
i guess that range is just how we keep
them somewhat in that matrix but
those are obviously a little too close
so you might want to like come up with
some better logic like i said i we're
we're here we're just playing in a
sandbox
so so i'm sure there's there's better
things that we can do over time but as
you um also
i think our supply you know went up to
up to like 63 or something like that so
um so that gives us room for more units
more probes possibly uh but the other
thing i do want to show actually before
um
the other thing i want to show is that
our nexus probably wound up with too
many probes for that nexus so the nexus
has like a limit of like 16 probes
and i i think like again i'm not the
expert here but from a quick look online
um it seemed to suggest like you can see
eventually we'll probably see so you see
like 17 18 19 20. um
you can have more than 16 and i think it
scales all the way up to 24 and then
everything out like so 16 is like the
most efficient worker
you know i guess every worker is very
efficient and then up to 24 it becomes
less and less efficient and then
anything beyond that the workers will
just sit there like you probably saw a
couple of them sitting there so
eventually you want to make sure that
you're just not making worthless probes
but before we've
built buildings and
built our other units i'm not too
worried about figuring out what should
that number be because it you could just
say you could limit your probes to be no
more than 16
but then if you're going to do that
eventually you're probably going to want
to expand and build more things or like
have probes that aren't necessarily
there to collect minerals but maybe
they're there to build further buildings
if we get under attack
so
yeah i really don't know so i just don't
have the answer so we're not going to
worry about that right now it's not a
problem right now because it's not it's
not like they're clogging up us to build
any other unit
so um so we built our pylons and now
that we've got pylons i think what we
should do is build our cannons so in
this case what was the last at least
that one about 1500 i think the first
game that we ran it was like 1600 that
we died at and then the game that we ran
before that
um
oh i guess
huh okay anyway somewhere between like i
guess one and two thousand still but
yeah at least these two were like
fifteen hundred and sixteen hundred
so let's build um the cannons and again
to build a cannon we are going to need
that like forge building so what we're
gonna do is again
order of importance we definitely must
have a nexus we can't do anything
without we can't do anything building
wise without at least a nexus once we
have a nexus we probably pylons are more
important than anything else at least
for this class this protoss class so the
next thing is
or where we're going to put the forge is
just going to be right after the pylons
at least in this case later we might
decide other things have a different
importance but for now the
with what we're planning to build the
least important thing now is the forge
but we still want one
so after we've done these things so l if
not self dot and in this case we can
check for structures so self.structures
and then here's our good friend unit
type id dot cat all caps forge
so
if we don't yet have a forge if we self
dot can underscore afford
a
unit
type id
dot
forge
then let's go ahead and await
a self.build
a unit type id
forge
uh forge there you are and then again we
have a
uh
near equals
and let me see what i did in the
tutorial here okay so in this case so
again everything has to be within that
little pylon matrix so in this case it
will be near
uh and i'm doing a self dot structures
self dot structures that text i don't
know if that text is too small for you
guys still or not
let me know in the chat if this text is
too small uh self dot structures it's
tough because these lines are pretty
long so i'm sorry for the cell phone
viewers but
i don't know how to make that any better
um
near self dot structures and then again
this will be a unit type id
dot pylon
so we want to build it near a pylon but
then also we probably want this stuff to
be like condensed into our like main
base area so we're going to say unit
typeid.pylon.closest
underscore2
that nexus
again we're selecting nexus purely by
we're saying all the nexuses and then a
random nexus so at some point if you
build more nexuses you might want to use
a different
thing like you might say nexus equals
self.town halls and then maybe the 0th
one or something like that
whatever so keep that in mind
um closest to the nexus cool so this
will build us hopefully a forge um
and then the other thing we might want
to say is i wonder if we can
i don't know if that'll be necessary i
would hate to build like multiple forges
but we await
i don't know
hopefully that won't be a problem uh
we'll see we'll just whatever if it's a
problem we wind up building like
multiple forges at the same time then
i'll worry about it um so software build
forge closest to the nexus so then
again l if
so
we'll build that forge otherwise and
again this whole time our little workers
apparently are just working all on their
own so um
so this stuff is not like screwing that
up like those guys seem to be just like
collecting minerals on their own so it's
not really a problem to be like just
this super long life chain that's not
going to block our resource connection
uh collection rather
so
if the forge um
will build it the next thing is we need
now if we do have a forge so elif
self.structures structures
uh unit
oops
unit type id
dot
forge
and then if that forge is dot ready
and
self dot structures
uh let's see here yeah okay self dot
structures
and of structures unit type id dot
photon
cannon in all caps
if that dot amount whoops dot amount is
less than three so if we have less than
three photon cannons i'm just wondering
too who would be following along on
mobile for starcraft ii
maybe that's impossible um if you're
running starcraft 2 on your phone
holler at me in the chat
uh so
so uh so if we have less than three so
we're just we're going to limit our
photon cannons again just like all these
other numbers i'm just like making these
numbers up so um feel free to like
tinker with various different numbers
maybe you want to build more cannons
there's even a strategy where you like
rush the enemy base and build a bunch of
cannons at their base
so so feel free to play with this uh you
could go with more or less or or
whatever so i'm just gonna say three for
now so if it's less than three what do
we wanna do well if it is less than
three then we're going to uh if self dot
can
afford so if we can't afford a unit uh
unit type id i almost want to like
alias this with something else so i
don't want to keep talking that but
that's okay
any type of id so if we can afford the
photon cannon
um then what we're going to do is await
whoops oh wait self.build
and we will build that unit type id
photon
cannon
and again we'll build that the thing
we're trying to protect really here is
our nexus so we'll build that near the
nexus and with that
i think we're pretty good um
now i did say that this won't like none
of this will interfere with our little
worker dudes
but at least one thing i did notice um
and in fact we'll just run this and i'll
point it out but it seems like once they
build a building they just like
hang out they don't do anything after
that so
um
hopefully we'll see an example of that
at the moment we have too many probes
anyways they end up going idle so it's
not really a big deal
but um it might be something we would
want to address so i'll at least address
that before we're done here but anyway
we can see here okay we got our forge
here's one cannon two cannons we might
again you know as with all the logic we
might
really ideally want to like spread these
out more or like figure out like for
example there's this like little ramp
and i think anything at least any ground
force that would want to attack us would
have to come up this ramp as they just
did um
how far along are we we're at 1300 wow
they
just came and attacked really quickly
didn't they
um i think these can't i'm not sure
what's going on with these cannons
what's the problem here is the supply no
i'm not really sure what happened to
those cannons i don't know if those are
actually working or not i don't think
that's how they look anyways it looks
like we are beginning to lose
um but we did survive quite a bit longer
we survived at least a few rounds of
attack
so again we're not going to win by
purely playing defense but it appears
that at least three cannons
does a thing now those workers did
i forgot to mention like the idol
workers and in fact let me just i'll
just break it here um let's solve the
the idle worker um you know what they
say about idle workers so so what we'll
do is
um
this will be outside of it's um if
self.town halls i guess
i'm trying to decide if this really i
don't know where this exactly should go
but first of all we'll just await
we'll just throw it outside of that if
statement await self dot distribute
distribute workers
so this will take your idle workers and
put them back to work
i'm also i think i'll just copy and
paste you don't have to have this if you
don't want but
if you want head over to the text based
version i'm not going to write this out
i'm not going to waste everybody's time
writing this out but this is a very long
print statement that basically tells us
the numbers of all of the things that at
least we'll be interested in in this
tutorial series at least for the next at
least one to two videos so so um this is
just telling us how many workers do we
have how many of them are idle how much
materials have we collected have we
gotten any gas which we haven't covered
yet but at least i showed you where the
gas was um how many cans do we have
pylons nexus gateways cybernetics cores
and then obviously so we need gateways
cybernetic scores stargates to build the
void rays and then finally supply so
this is just how much supply supply used
out of what is our actual full cap so
that just it just gives us a lot of
information that hopefully that way if
if we end a game again um and i forget
to look at a stat or something i can
just pull that up again um but again you
you don't really have to have all that
and like i said i'm not typing all that
out that would just be a waste of
everybody's time
okay so we're off uh
oh we didn't save
it's like where's my print
uh
wait for it again all right now we've
got our giant print statement so
as we can see okay we are building we've
got our forge up we've got our cannons
up they look to be placed horribly
yeah i think you'd maybe near nexus
towards the enemy or something like that
or you would want to find that ramp i
guess
okay so we we actually survived that
first attack which actually came around
a thousand frames which or a thousand
thousand steps rather
which is very interesting uh we lost a
lot of pylons i suppose workers why is
it i actually i couldn't even tell you
why is it worker zero over eight
um i don't even know someone tell me in
the chat below why why did our nexus
workers drop
anyway so um
so at least we're redistributing those
workers but probably yeah well they all
died at that point let's go
so we have 33 workers zero idle workers
so at least they're off doing something
but they are probably actually kind of
sort of idle because we have too many
workers for the nexus but we they can't
do anything anyways
but again i wouldn't really worry that
much about that simply because um
eventually we're going to build other
buildings and use up supply and use up
our various resources and we're probably
not going to be building just probes
like probes won't probes at the very
beginning are like they are at the
tippity top of our script essentially
but soon when we get to the point of
building like attack units those will
probably take priority over the probes
so i don't really foresee
that being a problem for long
otherwise i i think this is a good
stopping point we've we've built a few
buildings we've got a basic defense
forming here uh and i think uh the video
has gotten uh of a decent length so i'll
stop it here i will say um i for for
these videos i am i'm reading off of my
own notes so
um you might be wondering like okay well
how did you learn all of this stuff well
one is you can just read the package you
can go to the documentation and figure
out like
various things like these methods like
dot closest to and all this kind of
stuff there's so many
so many things that have just been done
for you
that are saving you a ton of time
through abstraction so
read the documentation there's also
example scripts so if you go to that
github there are example scripts that
you can read get ideas for like things
that you can do and all that so it's
it's not magic i haven't memorized this
library by any means
i'm just showing you some of the things
that are available to you and kind of
how to begin thinking about working with
this stuff
so uh that's all for now in the next
video
we will build an attack for us
and hopefully take on these uh this zerg
enemy and uh hopefully defeat them so
we'll see uh questions comments concerns
whatever you know the deal leave them
below otherwise i will see you guys in
another video
you